welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel
studios black widow
which finally tells the story of the
most secretive avenger and the blood on
her ledger really is the first mcu film
to release after a two-year gap it's
just welcome relief to appreciate all
the interesting filmmaking details the
mcu easter eggs and other hidden gems
that appear
all over this film spoiler warning and
let's dive into the past or
past and before we begin be sure to head
over to newrockstarsmerch.com for our
black widow inspired latest obsession
shirt i kind of play on the classic
hourglass logo
super limited supply we got another
black widow shirt design you might like
as well as some loki designs like the
gator loki polo shirt and the loki out
of time tea that i'm wearing get it all
at newrockstarsmerch.com here we go we
open in ohio 1995 where natasha romanov
age 11
played by ever anderson daughter of milo
djovic spent her youth with a family of
russian spies now these include
elena bilova florence pew but here
violet mcgraw
black widow's long time rival in the
comics alexis shostakov aka the red
guardian david harbor a soviet
counterpart to captain america
and molina vostikov rachel weiss aka the
iron maiden from the comics but from
this dysfunctional family
unit we get this film's central thematic
conflict forgiving
your family because the main events of
black widow are set right after captain
america civil war in 2016
two years before the avengers would
reunite infinity war but in this interim
period with her avengers family in this
kind of divorce
natasha romanov must both forgive and
seek forgiveness from her past family so
that she can learn to heal the family
that she chose
similar to the premise of the americans
on fx russian spy families are actually
a real world thing in 2010 the fbi
arrested 10 russian illegals
including four couples who had all been
living under cover in america for years
and you'll notice the opening credits
allude to this with a tv report from
w-h-i-h
that's marvel's in-universe news service
about natasha's family being outed
evoking those reports that we saw in
2010 but the year 1995 is an eventful
one in mcu history as
shield was stretched thin dealing with
the skrulls and the cree and the return
of carol danvers in the events of
captain marvel
but also elsewhere in the universe
gamora was taken from her native people
and turned into a deadly weapon by
thanos
parallel to the girl soldier future
awaiting these two
young natasha has blue hair covering up
her red roots all already foretelling a
life of hair
alteration and masking her red the
sisters exchanged this whistle
which they echo to say goodbye at the
end of the film
and the opening lines of this film are
also bookended
upside down and i bet you're gonna fall
out first
and later when natasha finds the elaine
on the ground elena says
we're both upside down after stealing a
secret government disk they have to flee
and they play helena's favorite song don
mclean's american pie
a song about the 1959 plane crash that
killed early rock and roll stars buddy
holly richie valens and the big bopper
a song that many interpret as a kind of
allegory for american pop culture
throughout the 50s and 60s with all
these crazy specific references that don
mclean has cryptically never
acknowledged what they actually mean but
generally it is about
american disillusionment of that era but
interestingly elena just likes a song
for its simple catchy melody not really
realizing the darker truth of the lyrics
much like the way she sees her life in
ohio as just pure and genuine without
really understanding the darkness of
what's going on notice how the song
plays over some departing images of
americana including a football game
recalling the lyrics of the fourth verse
of american pie about a football game
halftime marching band refusing to leave
the field which some say could have
really been about the beatles rock
takeover with sergeant pepper and in the
shot you can see the marching band on
the far
end of the field there when they get to
the plane alexi clears away by showing
some surprising super strength
notice how the trailer flips with just a
solid thud no bounce
just a subtle animation effect showing
how heavy this thing is now they're
pursued by
shield suvs not those of the fbi or even
the local pd
indicating that they're not being chased
because they're russian spies but
because they interfered with a shield
operation which we learn more about when
they arrive in cuba and meet with
general drakov
and the north institute
yes the north institute is from a 2004
run of black widow comics the institute
worked on behalf of the gynecon
corporation
i know it's called the gynecon
corporation but they were killing off
widow agents after they purchased
russian biotech
from the red room's successor but in
this film it's a similar program but run
by
shield which was secretly run by hydra
at the time in conjunction with their
winter soldier program to produce a
cellular
map of the inner brain for chemically
induced mind control but
drakov is a familiar name in the mcu
first mentioned by
loki all the way back in the first
avengers film i got read in my lecture
i'd like to wipe it out can you
can you wipe out that much red
drakov's daughter and yes we will meet
drakov's daughter very soon but these
opening titles are scored by nirvana's
smells like teen spirit but covered by
think up anger featuring malia j now
this song was written by kurt cobain as
an anarchic anthem for disaffected gen
xers
but now through this female voice it's
used to convey these girls being
converted into mindless assets for the
interests of the powerful notice how
natasha breaks away to give you elena
something folded
this was the photo booth strip that she
took from the car which elena later uses
in the movie to mark her message for
natasha the montage shows a close-up of
drakov's ring which
later is the key that natasha uses to
unlock and download all the red room
data the montage shows footage of them
staging home videos of christmas and
other holidays as natasha reveals later
that all the photos in their albums were
shot on a single day with different
backdrops to make them look like a
convincingly american family we see a
close-up of a red hair bow
rotating to become the hourglass shape
of the black widow logo
now on a human target similar to the
ones natasha remembered shooting at in
her red room flashbacks in age of ultron
but were actually people we see imagery
of the north institute file
and pigs a clue for how melina will use
the north institute data to test mind
control on pigs first but then later on
humans that are being used as
metaphorical pigs for the slaughter and
then all these crazy photos of drakov
photoshopped in the photos with various
world leaders including jimmy carter
bill clinton boris yeltsin condoleezza
rice and vladimir putin yeah so much for
this guy staying in the shadows and we
catch up with natasha romanov 21 years
later in 2016 right after civil war when
she was on the run william hurt returns
as thaddeus ross and says
tasha is in violation of the sokovia
accords
she assaulted the king of wakanda
yes referring to the superhero
registration law that captain america
refused to sign and natasha despite
initially agreeing with tony stark
swung over to team cap by attacking
black panther to allow cap and bucky to
escape
and ross tells her we got barton we got
wilson and the other guy the incredible
shrinking convict
referring to the members of team cap who
at this point were still imprisoned on
the raft including hawkeye and falcon
and the incredible shrinking convict is
ant-man scott lang and i love how he
uses the hulk's incredible moniker for
that natasha brings up ross's triple
bypass surgery that he used to explain
his absence at the start of civil war
but she slips on by actually being on a
ferry to norway girl i'll get
you black widow in morocco adult elena
bulova leads a team
targeting an older widow roxanna who
sprays the elena with the antidote to
the widow's chemical subjugation i like
how during their knife fight yelena
drops a knife from one hand to the other
i love that move natasha actually later
uses it while fighting taskmaster just
showing some of their parallel training
there we first meet taskmaster as they
watched footage from the civil war
airport battle of hawkeye fighting black
panther that was actually updated from
the trailer version of the shot that
showed taskmaster watching footage of
natasha and iron man 2. so in the comics
taskmaster is tony masters a mercenary
and assassin with photographic reflexes
that mirror the combat style of any
combatant but this film changes the
character too
as we learn in the third act of the film
antonia drakov's daughter with all of
her mirrored fighting not being an
innate physical skill but instead based
on some fighting analysis algorithm in
her heads-up display in her helmet and
the chip that's in the back of her head
so she's a bit more
terminatory now but i'll say this is
similar to the upgrade in iron man's
mark 46
armor that he used to also predict cap's
fighting combat style in civil war in a
safe house natasha meets her contact
rick mason otf bendlay
passports a couple of local drivers
licenses
fanny longbottom yeah later on in the
post-credits scene elena names her dog
fanny and then this exchange there's
some mail and personals from the
budapest safe house budapest
yeah uh budapest no it's it's budapest
through the past
yes natasha is using the hungarian
pronunciation calling back her exchange
with hawkeye in avengers
just like budapest all over again you
and i remember budapest very differently
natasha looks at some blonde hair dyes
setting up how she will change her hair
by the end of this film to set up her
look in avengers infinity war and she
watches the
07 roger moore film moonraker with some
surprisingly
similar plot points as black widow
including a skydive parachute sequence
that people definitely should not have
survived and a hidden
base floating in secret above earth but
taskmaster attacks natasha using a
shield with a discus hurl that she
likely got from watching footage of
captain america and i love this detail
when natasha crawls out of her vehicle
looking for taskmaster notice how the
vehicle suddenly stops
teetering even though without nat
nothing would be weighing down that side
of the vehicle telling us that it was
taskmaster who had landed on top of it
natasha tries to take down taskmaster
with her
classic scissors maneuver but taskmaster
uses it right back on her now within
taskmaster's heads up display
on the right are the words evaluating
defensive measures with on the left a
predict percentage and a threat
percentage and then various pressure
points on her body with percentages
maybe to show how effective a blow to
that region would be or how likely
natasha is to use it and again yes this
is very similar to stark's mark 46
text so much so that i'm wondering if a
version or an early prototype of it
could have been stolen from stark's
research they do simultaneous flip jumps
to their feet
something that natasha remembers as a
move she later uses in combination with
the downward punch
to release the antidote on her and then
in the second scan taskmaster's display
shows two numbers per arm the top of
which may correspond to the likelihood
she'll strike with that side the bottom
maybe meaning how much of a threat that
strike would be
and then the directive has changed to
redirect to primary target meaning that
all of this is being viewed remotely by
dracov giving her commands moment to
moment natasha lasso's taskmaster to the
overhead beam but taskmaster slashes it
and swings into this acrobatic flip
maybe a move that she got from watching
videos of spider-man that we know are on
youtube at this point and knocks natasha
off the ledge but with her the vials so
natasha takes these to budapest where
she spars with yelena and then after the
fight she asks
what bullet does that
bullets arrows another reminder of
natasha and hawkeyes passed in budapest
and perhaps this was some scuffle after
their attempt to kill dracob which
natasha reveals was the final step in
her defection to shield
elena didn't want natasha to bring the
vials back here she wanted her to give
them to her scientist friends of the
avengers like tony stark but natasha
says they aren't talking just one
example of how the civil war really just
left the world a less
safe place they're chased by other
widows one tragically breaks her leg so
drakov decides to terminate her remotely
from his tablet yikes taskmaster chases
them in a freaking tank
plowing through the cars on the street
as they are fleeing on a motorcycle and
with taskmaster's terminator essence
it's just hard not to see this as an
homage to the chase sequence in t2
judgment day natasha and elena hide from
taskmaster in a ceiling vent
martin and i spent two days hiding out
up here the doodles include a hawkeye
arrow some games of tic-tac-toe in a
game of hangman it's hard to make out
what the word was supposed to be
but based on the letters and the wrong
letters already chosen i'm gonna guess
butterfly a flashback shows that
budapest mission with natasha tracking
drakov's daughter
[Music]
yeah that sound effect of antonia
stepping out of the car is
a modulated version of the sound
taskmaster made earlier when she hopped
out of the car to confront natasha on
the bridge
just a little clue telling us that they
are the same person elena explains that
the reason draykov was able to stay
off of natasha's radar or never tried to
kill her was to stay hidden from the big
avengers
wait what are the big ones well i doubt
the god from space has to take an
ibuprofen after a fight
of course referencing thor though thor
was off world during civil war but this
video was sponsored by expressvpn now
that shows like rick and morty are back
do you want to re-watch old seasons but
your streaming service doesn't have it
well expressvpn can help you with that
because expressvpn is a virtual private
network that encrypts your data to keep
it from being
stolen or tracked express3bn allows you
to reroute your connection to a server
in a country of your choice making
geo-restrictions a thing of the past
like the us netflix doesn't have rick or
morty but the uk netflix does
you can open up yourself to a whole new
library of content without having to pay
for a whole new streaming service you
don't even have to clone your daughter
to make it work expressvpn is also
helpful for preventing your online data
from being stolen or monitored without
your knowledge
i like how easy expressvpn is to use no
confusion no wasted time and the whole
thing runs fast
just fire up the app and connect with
just one click it's a top rated vpn
provider rated number one by techradar
cnet and many more
find out how you can get three months of
expressvpn for free by visiting
expressvpn.com new rockstars or clicking
the link in the description below elena
mocks
natasha's landing pose with the hair
flip back
it's a fighting pose you're a total
poser not a poser one of my favorite
running jokes of the movie but also an
example of how to elena and natasha's
family of the avengers seems like a joke
a way of hitting back at her for natasha
saying elena thinking her
ohio family was so great that being a
joke later they talk about their parents
did you ever look for your parents your
real ones
my mom abandoned me in the straight like
garbage
an endgame natasha would be shaken to
hear red skull call her
daughter of ivan meaning she has some
father out there named ivan but back in
infinity war he also called gamora
daughter of thanos when he was not her
biological father just a very hands-on
paternal figure
so really this leaves this ivan guy a
mcu mystery
elena says she invented histories for
them all my sister moved out west
is that right you're a science teacher
your husband
he renovates houses i like to think of
this hypothetical life as natasha mary
and bruce banner who
does in a way renovate houses elena
mentions wanting a dog which she does
get in the post-credits scene
on the drive elena says see my vest
it has a lot of pockets but i use them
all the time
i've never had control over my own life
before and now i do
so when she gives this vest to natasha
and nat shows up wearing this same vest
in infinity war it's not just about the
pockets folks it is a symbol of she and
her sister having more control over
their lives and we catch up with alexi
in prison
[Music]
that guardian's time i grab hold of his
shield
a test of strength yeah the other
prisoner is right to point out if this
was 1983 or 84
steve rogers was still frozen in ice and
assuming alexia had been in prison for
longer than five years it's impossible
for the two to have ever
met or capped to have any idea who he is
and alexi goes on with this story
anyway this shield you know that he
carries with him like
like a precious baby blanket you know i
i use it to my advantage i dig it i push
him out the window
what do you think about it alexi does
get a kind of victory moment this way in
the final sequence using the shield to
his advantage to smash a soldier through
the window of the jet his prison tattoos
are
awesome including a russian imperial
eagle on his chest and carl
and marks across his knuckles natasha
and elena send him a red guardian action
figure
yeah it sounds like david harper
actually recorded the russian
catchphrase for the toy and i love that
natasha and elena assumed he would be
wistful enough to pull that
string so that he would find the
earpiece in the head on their tablet
this prison is called
seventh circle prison which is the name
of a run of the punisher daredevil
comics but
also the circle in hell and dante's
inferno for souls that have committed
acts of violence
alexi is strong enough to break glass
and kick down the doors but
not to climb the second level perhaps
justifying why he was unable to escape
in the past natasha does her pose
landing elena blows the tower which
triggers an avalanche and alexis
springboard's office shield to make it
up finally similar to that moment in the
avengers when natasha springboarded from
capshield to hop up to some chatari and
then after lifting him out yolanda hits
alexi for abandoning them and he asks if
it's her time of the month to which they
respond
i don't have a uterus yeah that's what
happens when the red room gives you an
involuntary hysterectomy yes a much more
vivid description of what natasha
described in age of ultron to bruce
banner
they have a graduation ceremony they
sterilize you
it's efficient one less thing to worry
about so they find molina on her pig
farm where she's using mind control tech
to guide these pigs through a maze like
lab rats i just feel so bad for these
pigs especially that alexi one the one
she nearly suffocates
of course not to mention the human test
subjects whom she never really seems to
feel that bad about torturing
we stole the key to unlocking free will
the world functions on a higher level
when it is controlled
which leads to an argument over whether
they were true family at any point
our family was never real so there's
nothing to hold on to
please don't say that it was real
it was real to me you are my mother you
were my real mother
but afterwards melina and natasha end up
coming together over natasha learning
that her biological mother continued to
look for her and then was killed off by
draco
i just feel like melina switch comes a
bit too quickly as if she might have had
another agenda here like she could have
revealed this to natasha in order to
gain her trust but really to further
incentivize natasha to kill drakov in
order to remove him from the widow
program and allow melina to step in and
take over the operation like i just have
a lot of questions about her plan the
way she has only one earpiece set which
is kind of a weird detail almost like
melina wanted all the communication of
this plan to go through her
and this plan was to offer to help land
the red room right into ross's lap even
though that could end up with her behind
bars
and she does this by sneaking into the
engine control room
of a base that she designed and
therefore would know that drakov would
be watching her so that she would have
to
oopsie daisy dos vidanya the engine to
crash the whole thing that would
conveniently destroy all evidence of her
role in this chemically subjugating
women
program i am just saying things lucked
out pretty great for the iron maiden
let's keep an eye on that one but back
while they're talking elena snaps at
alexi the only thing you care about are
your stupid glory days is the crimson
dynamo and no one wants to hear about it
it's the red guardian crimson dynamo was
another russian marvel villain for whom
in iron man 2 they took the name
anton vanko ivan vanko's father and
ivan's fake id
bore the name boris turganev who was the
second crimson dynamo in the comics
drakov's forces arrive and elena finds
natasha or who she thinks is natasha but
in that closet the
masks are no longer hanging and the red
and brunette wigs are taken away just a
clue that natasha and molina must have
swapped and they go to the red room a
floating base somehow hidden in the
clouds
now you'll know how draco stayed above
the radar all these years
kind of a weird thing to say but
remember natasha is a big fan of double
07 a genre where the villains tend to
declare their plans loud and so by doing
this natasha gives alexi details that he
otherwise might not have had which might
be why
taskmaster immediately re-sedates him so
natasha disguised as melina meets with
dracov who gets right up in her face
right away
it's a painting my ass
yeah notice he inhales through his nose
briefly and then shortly after he cuts
her off and forces her to sit while
gripping her head
yeah he may have caught from this moment
or even from her scent that this is not
the real molina and then just plays
along and then as draco boxes her in
saying natasha is a traitor the light
from outside dims on his face and then
the jig is up
when you look into the eyes of a child
you have raced
no mask in the world can hide then
yeah yeah spy [ __ ] natasha previously
used a similar mask in captain america
the winter soldier and more recently
sharon carter used one of these in the
falcon and the winter soldier
in drakov's office hangs a portrait of
rasputin this was the mystic healer and
advisor to the final russian royal
family of tsar nicholas ii reflecting
how drakov might see himself as the man
with the magic touch
running the empire from the shadows but
really an empire that is about to topple
due to a violent revolution when drakov
tells antonia to reveal herself she does
so by hitting a specific button on her
buzz lightyear panel something natasha
notices and then later uses in the final
blows of the fight on the ground to pop
open her helmet so that she can spray
her dracoff reveals he has been making
widow
agents out of girls all over the world
it's kind of impossible to count all
them on the screen but by going by the
little red square since we know each of
them is a face
looks like about 48 rows down and at
least three times that wide so around
7 000 widows or more which is an
insanely huge
army of assassins but notice how this
map shows
no widows illuminated in the wakanda
region now this is still right after
civil war wakanda has not yet revealed
itself as a major world power people
just think it's a small poor farming
country but really drakov's talk about
toppling world empires really would not
have upset the global status quo
that much if wakanda remains standing
and once drakov shows his cards by
saying he runs it all from that control
pad
natasha responds thank you for your
cooperation a callback to avengers when
she tricked loki into revealing his plan
thank you for your cooperation so that
dasha severs her olfactory nerve so that
she can attack dracov and you can see
the moment she snatches his ring when
she places her hand on his on the
control pad goes right over the ring and
as he falls back
no ring drakov's glasses fall off as she
hits him but when the widows save him he
puts them back on signaling how he's
back in control
but setting up when he dies his glasses
fly off
after elena blows his getaway jets
engine meanwhile taskmaster's fighting
alexi showing off some
vibranium claws like black panther and
kickflips the shield just like cap's big
move also notice taskmaster shows that
she's been watching footage of the
winter soldier as well because she does
bucky's signature knife flip natasha
fights the other widows as the red light
from drakov's world map
beams the faces of the other girls onto
their own faces just showing how all
these women are connected fighting for
the fates of all the women around the
globe
the elena hits them all with an antidote
grenade and as natasha downloads the
data about the other widows
their faces flicker past creating this
kind of michael jackson black or white
music video effect where they all merge
into one
just another display of how all their
forced servitude connects them in a way
when natasha frees taskmaster from the
cell taskmaster's heads-up display in
the helmet flickers
a little sign to natasha that the
prediction algorithm is glitching and
she might have a chance to break through
to her
the base explodes and crashes late into
this insane
skydive battle and to stop her sister
from falling
first echoing the first scene natasha
dives after her with a parachute and
then miraculously makes it to the ground
safely enough natasha gets a scissor
kick that antonia is unable to
reciprocate so natasha can open her
helmet and punch
the vial in the aftermath of all this
the family makes their peace
if it can work out with the four of us
you know there may be some hope for the
avengers
yes this movie's way of linking the
forgiving family theme with natasha's
coming conflicts alongside the avengers
which natasha echoes again in the final
scene it's funny my whole life i didn't
think i had any family
turns out i got two so one of them's a
bit of a mess right now i'm gonna go
break a few of them out of prison see if
i can't help patch things up
with her short blonde hair and yelena's
vest she is ready for when we would
chronologically see her next in infinity
war now timeline wise this would set all
the 2016 events of black widow just in a
few days during the epilogue of civil
war linking back up with cap as he broke
the others out of the raft at the very
end of that film and then still leaving
it a big mystery what they were all
doing for two years on the run
after this and as she takes off in the
quinjet the music is
alan silvestri's avengers theme
leaving us with the shot of the
fireflies in the trees just like in the
opening scene but now visually linking
with the glows on the world map each
glow
representing one of the forgotten lives
that these sisters have now
put on a path to liberation now i broke
down the post-credits scene in a whole
other video go check that out but that
is everything i noticed in black widow
more videos will be coming out on this
channel about this movie soon so be sure
to subscribe to new rockstars follow me
at eavos follow new rockstars thanks for
watching those vidania douchebags
[Music]
you